russia's naval strength on full display
in the black sea
part of regular drills it carries out
throughout the year
and in the country's southwest more
troops and military hardware are taking
part in live fire exercises but russia
has dismissed u.s warnings it is about
to invade ukraine
there won't be a war as far as it
depends on the russian federation we
don't want a war but we won't let our
interests be rudely trampled on and
ignored
the us has rejected all the russian
security proposals for the last two or
three years
now they're putting the same things on
the table in other words they're
borrowing from recent russian
initiatives this is something at least
one of moscow's strongest allies and a
neighbor to the north has reiterated its
support for russia and says that the two
countries are only interested in
self-defense
so will there be a war or not yes there
will be but only in two cases if direct
aggression is committed against belarus
if a hot war is unleashed against our
belarus and the second possibility of
war to happen and for belarus to take
part in it is for our ally the russian
federation is directly attacked if the
same aggression is committed against the
territory of the russian federation
russia and belarus are due to begin 10
days of joint military exercises next
month the biggest ever held but on the
streets of moscow people say it's russia
that's being provoked
i believe america wants to provoke
russia by any means we live decently now
in russia i'm 70 years old and i can say
we have never lived better than now they
feel threatened by this and are trying
to destabilize us it all smells our
provocations
half of the people i know are ukrainian
i can't believe there will be war i
can't believe it
it's the conflict of politicians rather
than ordinary people ukrainians are our
relatives
russia never attack anyone and it's
never going to we only defend it's the
united states who escalate in the whole
situation because it's profitable for
them president vladimir putin has spoken
to his french counterpart emmanuel
macron about russia's deep unease with
nato's eastward expansion so the
diplomatic window is still open to avert
what could be a disastrous conflict for
all sides
dorsotabari al jazeera moscow